dieses Pesto kannst du dir zubereiten
während deine Nudeln kochen und ich sage
dir so viel das Endergebnis wird euch
überzeugen und dafür brauchen wir
natürlich sonnengetrocknete Tomaten
Pinienkerne Chili Knoblauch Olivenöl und
paramila Tomaten rein zack es folgen die
gerösteten Pinienkerne sie sind wirklich
geröstet schaut und gehen wir dazu eine
Chili müsst ihr nicht reinmachen wenn
ihr keine Schärfe mögt ich will es ein
bisschen Spice hier eine Knoblauchzehe
Olivenöl Andy Mix
oh das sieht doch schon mal gut aus es
fehlt uns noch der Parmesan und wir
reiben einiges davon hinein jetzt noch
den Parmesan unterheben und wenn du dich
noch ein bisschen Salz aus der Block
salzbox dazugeben wie kriege ich das
jetzt sauber mit dem Block scraper ins
Block
Boardshop wir können unsere Nudeln
rausholen da darf ruhig ein bisschen
Nudelwasser mitkommen ordentlich Pesto
rosso dazu und wir mixen
die platzieren die Nudeln wir haben noch
gefühlt genauso viel wieder vor und ein
perfekten Teller Nudeln mit Pesto